180 voiture gisant sur la chaussée
paris par le plus navrant des petits
matins faisait le bilan de la nuit
dramatique du quartier latin 3 167
blessés dont une vingtaine dans un état
grave
neuf jours plus tôt à la faculté d'un
auteur à la suite de l'agitation de
groupes d'étudiants des cours avaient
été suspendus ce qui équivalait à une
fermeture le lendemain à 17 heures la
police était appelée à la sorbonne la
décision déclenché la colère des
étudiants
trois mines crs et gardes mobiles
avaient pris place au quartier latin
l'escaladent était engagé une semaine un
pitoyable commencer daniel cohn bendit
et sept autres étudiants de nanterre
comparaissent devant le conseil de
discipline la sorbonne la manifestation
organisée par l'unef s'amplifie
c'est l'affrontement
boulevard saint germain les pavés de
l'eau note paul dix mille étudiants sont
dans les rues engagés dans une lutte
acharnée avec les policiers
dans la nuit vient la violence atteint
son paroxysme la manifestation sera 600
blessés il y aura 4 122 arrestation dans
trente et une maintenu une nouvelle
manifestation organisée pour protester
contre la fermeture de la sorbonne et
les arrestations aux vingt mille
étudiants le défilé dans paris du 5
heures sans incident
1009 et le snes ou pour donner en lots
aux étudiants à 18h30 à la halle aux
vins au milieu des étudiants un prix
nobel
alfred kastler
à l'assemblée nationale le ministre
monsieur peyrefitte à envisager la
réouverture des facultés clair que ce
qu'il s'agit de reprendre ce sont des
cours se sont pas une manifestation de
violence dans les amphithéâtres
une telle mesure ne peut pas être pris
dans un climat de désordre et de
violence au quartier latin le préfet de
police est venue vérifier le dispositif
on craint un assaut de la sorbonne mais
la manifestation s'achève sans incident
on espère à la sorbonne au recteur jean
roche annonce que la reprise des cours
ne pourra se faire que progressivement
la sorbonne restée fermée et gardée
assis sur la chaussée 3000 étudiants
déçu écoute les commentaires de daniel
cohn bendit c'est la journée de la
déception la faculté de nanterre est
ouverte peu de court peu de lait les
étudiants n'ont pas cherché à occuper la
fac le calme aurait la sorbonne quant à
elle est toujours bien gardé
à 18 ans il y a trente mille
manifestants place denfert rochereau aux
étudiants se sont joints des lycéens
le dispositif cependant est renforcée à
la sorbonne
des milliers de policiers quadrillent
systématiquement les alentours à d'en
faire un mot d'ordre a été lancé
récup et le quartier latin les
manifestants sont décidés à ne pas céder
le terrain avant d'avoir obtenu
satisfaction des négociations commencent
et dans la nuit la tension atteint son
point culminant
prise d'assaut par les crs les
barricades brûle derrière chacune donne
les étudiants résiste avec tout
l'acharnement de leur jeunesse et de
leur conviction vous êtes une véritable
bataille qui va durer quatre heures les
grenades lacrymogènes dont on parlera
longtemps explose et tout au long de la
nuit mais secours aux blessés poseront
un grave problème
l'aube s'est levée sur un spectacle
désolant
on évacue encore des étudiants blessés
un prix nobel n'a cessé de s'occuper
d'eux le professeur mono et tandis qu on
fait le bilan de la nuit on se demande
ce que réserve la nouvelle journée qui
commence
entouré du secrétaire général du snes
sup et de cohn-bendit le vice président
de l'unef affirme trois objectifs nous
disons de façon extrêmement clair que
nous avons nettement défini quels
étaient les trois points à partir
desquels une fois ces points a admis
pour s engager une négociation c'est à
dire amnistie de tous les manifestants
condamnés arrêt des poursuites
judiciaires administratives et
universitaire deuxièmement réouverture
des facultés
troisièmement disparition des forces de
police des universités et des quartiers
universitaires
un problème qui se pose avec d'autant
plus d'ampleur que 460 arrestations ont
été opérées à la suite de la nuit des
barricades
les syndicats ont décidé une grève
générale pour lundi suivant l'apaisement
cependant viendra le soir avec
l'initiative que prendra le premier
ministre à son retour d'iran et
d'afghanistan
j'ai décidé que la seule serait
librement rouverte à partir de lundi les
cours reprenant à la diligence du
recteur et des doyens à partir de lundi
également la cour d'appel pourra
conformément à la loi
statuer sur les demandes de libération
des étudiants condamnés journée de répit
journée de la méditation
les parisiens que l'événement a
bouleversé sont venus visiter le
quartier latin meurtre
les forces de police quitte le périmètre
de la sorbonne
la vieille faculté rouvre ses pas les
ponts cependant seront encore garder
l'ordre de grève a été maintenu par les
quatre grandes centrales syndicales
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes défileront de la place de la
république à denfert-rochereau en
passant à l'hôtel de ville
elles apprendront la libération des
quatre étudiants emprisonnés
oh
on
en
oh